Nếu mà chân gà kai thì hôm vứa ai cũng nghĩ này để chân gà miệng trang
Quản cảnh bầu với người rất là nhiều năm
Tổ thử một kịt chỉ quen tuộc
Từ giờ chẻ, dù hách một khám tỏa ở bục điểm xuống
Mình này mới nói ngắm
Mình sẽ lấy mình nào cũng tươi mẹ là vòng ngoài
Mình sẽ tươi mẹ là tâm môi hả mừng
Mình có không thang dạm, nó mừng xí hì mạng
Mình sẽ tầy châu rồi, sau và được gít đến
Mình sẽ tầy châu, nó mừng xíc tên cáo
Mình bỏ kịt hợp với rạc
Từ năm 2020, mừng tầy châu
Mình sẽ tầy châu, đừng có tấm thân gà
Tầy châu, đừng có tấm gà bố
Một tầy châu, đừng có tấm gà bố
Mình có thể chứ dung là kỳ lỳ a y của đá
Gì cũng dơ ninh bật tìm mạnh
Họng mọi nó đẩy người còn gạo
Vì vầy mất còn người ui hụi gọi mạng hân
Mình bàn xịt giến nhẹn gà
Mình là mắt thánh thêm với tất sẻ
Mình tầy châu, nó tháng mắt, vui vẻ
Khi cầy mấy màn tất sẻ là tầy chung thích
Họng mất lắm
Chứ ngà là tẻ 2 chức mỏ
Bộ khó này, hòa lấu này, bây sao này
Sôi thì thó này, pương mặt, các bạn đó
Đặt tâm mại lòng, nó sẽ lắng vụ quảng, là tính ra sợ tắc.
Sợ tại tụi tây, sợ tây hồi à, sợ tế mê thái, sợ mê thái.
Sợ tụi mình của khách hàng không chỉ dụng ở mấy.
Hí hợt các cùng gặp phút, trên đàn biên trang lịch kiếp tạm thích nhiều tự khách mới,
từ bây hủy bất dụt tạm mòn ông này,
thì xúc khách phút xa thì chỉ bước viết đặc xa thì.
Quảng quảng, trên đàn, mặt đình gió,
được đại truyền quảng được khách hàng,
tất cả yêu thương nhất, phải lì cháu dài quảng,
sự gián hủy.
Mà cũng như ra lạc, bây giờ thách lấy cậu cậu khách,